obrigado as cidades transformadas podem
transformar as pessoas
eu tenho convicção nessa idéia
sou vereador iata arquiteta urbanista ao
longo da minha vida profissional e
trabalhou em vários projetos que
transformaram a cidade do rio de janeiro
e hoje eu trabalho faz parte da equipe
de municipal que está na gestão da
prefeitura de niterói
fiz um doutorado em barcelona
estudei várias cidades do mundo
suas origens como elas cresceram se
desenvolveram com mais modelos de
crescimento que tipo de planejamento
urbano mas me interessei mas me dediquei
em aprofundar nos estudos sobre a cidade
do rio de janeiro o rio como todos sabem
tem sua origem no extinto morro do
castelo
ironicamente por uma ironia da história
esse morro desapareceu já parece um
pouco da história da cidade do rio ea
cidade teve que driblar uma condição de
topografia difícil uma condição
topografia é difícil pra crescer para se
desenvolver para acomodar sua população
acomodar o seu crescimento e talvez é
uma das experiências de transformação
mais contundentes da cidade do rio tenha
sido a reforma do prefeito pereira
passos que no início do século 20
transformou uma cidade colonial de ruas
estreitas da cidade acanhada uma cidade
moderna uma cidade com amplas avenidas
uma cidade cosmopolita
essa reforma foi tão importante que a
própria prefeitura teve que
exigiu que a prefeitura fizesse algumas
posturas municipais
uma das posturas proibia que as pessoas
andassem descalça que andar sem sapatos
nas novas praças na praça quinze símbolo
símbolo dessa modernidade bom dando um
salto da praça quinze daquele início do
século 20 para duas experiências que eu
participei
já agora no final do século 20
queria contar duas experiências para
vocês a primeira foi sobre a renovação a
reorganização da orla marítima da cidade
o rio é a que era um cartão postal da
cidade carioca que sua orla suas praias
ali no final dos anos 80 e início dos 90
tinham pequenas barraquinhas né aqueles
e aquelas carrocinhas de pipoqueiro
vendendo alimentos e bebidas foi nesse
momento que a prefeitura e realizou um
projeto de transformação substituindo
essas carrocinhas pelos quiosques
padronizados e ordenados neste espaço da
orla do rio de janeiro
foi nesse momento também é quando se
construiu uma das primeiras ciclovias da
cidade
a ciclovia que se estende do leme ao
pontal que passou ali pelo jardim de
alah que deu a volta na lagoa rodrigo de
freitas
para vocês terem uma ideia é naquele
momento nós construímos 20 quilômetros
de ciclovias
hoje o rio tem mais de 300 km de
ciclovias espalhados por toda a cidade e
para contar uma história curiosa
eu tenho um amigo um jovem amigo tem
pouco mais de 30 anos ele me conta com
muito entusiasmo e contou com muito
entusiasmo que ganhou uma bicicleta de
natal quando tinha lá seus 13 para 14
anos e pode estrear sua bicicleta na
ciclovia refém inaugurada da praia de
copacabana
ele pode descobrir a cidade com a
bicicleta
a siano de bicicleta esse meu amigo
hoje ele é arquiteto e urbanista uma
segunda experiência que eu vivi aqui na
cidade do rio de janeiro foi a renovação
da praça quinze anos já a meados do der
na década de 90 s decidiu é por
reorganizar aquela praça é a praça
estava ocupado por carros ônibus e
bloqueando a passagem entre a estação
das barcas e o centro da cidade um
contingente de população enorme que
circulava por ali e que contava sempre
aquele bloqueio de ônibus e carros
parados na frente é pré não permitindo
nem amar acessibilidade mais confortável
então o projecto de requalificação e
renovação da praça é foi é foi elaborado
com a construção do mergulhão que está
aí até hoje
e à praça então ganhou uma ampla
esplanada com um piso paginado em
granito é livre de obstáculos né ficou
uma praça realmente digna de um já no
final de século e onde antes onde cem
anos antes a população foi proibida de
andar sem sapatos né e foi proibida de
andar descalça nessa praça a praça
quinze e inundou de skatistas e
patinadores uma nova cultura urbana
aconteceu nesse espaço a praça quinze
então renovada está vivendo um outro
momento da sua existência na cidade do
rio
e já que estamos falando de praça quinze
eu vou convidar vocês para atravessarem
de barca comigo imaginariamente até
niterói que é a cidade para onde eu me
desloco cada dia para trabalhar na
prefeitura e chegando em niterói
nós vamos encontrar pela praça araribóia
a passar de bóia que há uns tantos está
no centro da cidade está no coração da
cidade
o centro se esvaziou centro perdeu
população as pessoas foram morar em
outros bairros
esse esvaziamento populacional e
econômico fez com que os espaços
públicos se degradassem ea prefeitura
decidiu intervir realizar um projeto de
transformação dessa praça mas como obter
os recursos necessários para uma obra de
tal magnitude de recuperar todo um
centro de renovar todo um centro de
cidade
quais os mecanismos disponíveis para
conseguir os investimentos necessários
o estatuto das cidades de 2001 trouxe
alguns instrumentos tributários
urbanísticos e instrumentos que preveem
com essa valorização do solo pode ser
capturada pelas prefeituras para os
investimentos desejados necessários para
a renovação daquele espaço público eu
vou passar um vídeo pra vocês um vídeo
inédito que vai falar sobre esse projeto
de transformação na área central de
niterói
por favor o vídeo
mas vamos ver então como está niterói
hoje niterói possui uma população de
aproximadamente
aproximadamente meio milhão de
habitantes 500 mil pessoas hoje circulam
pelo centro
todos os dias é uma população gente que
vem de barca de ônibus de carro pela
ponte rio niterói que vem até que vem de
bicicleta é um centro é que congrega
toda essa população circulando mas hoje
os espaços públicos não estão adequados
para esse contingente de pessoas que
circulam cada dia as calçadas são
estreitas inadequadas
a fiação aérea
ela está exposta por todas as ruas do
irã o emaranhado de fios
ele não se incomoda pelo aspecto
estético mas em dias de chuva o vento
forte falta luz para comércios e
residências
o patrimônio histórico está em condições
muito precárias de preservação não
condiz com uma cidade equipe gosta
deseja preservar sua memória sua
história à frente marítima hoje
apresenta é um mar de estacionamentos
ali é localizados obstruindo a vista
para o mar e obstruindo um espaço que
poderia ser um espaço de lazer um espaço
para se desenvolver desenvolver a
indústria do turismo
enfim um espaço nobre de uma cidade à
beira-mar
nós estamos planejando então um projeto
de transformação do centro de niterói
as ruas serão requalificados
as praças e parques serão renovados
vamos construir ciclovias vamos
construir novas redes de drenagem nova
rede de saneamento
o projeto prevê o conforto da cidade
para os seus cidadãos
o projeto prevê que as pessoas possam
voltar a viver outra vez no centro da
cidade ao centro que ficou esvaziado
o projeto prevê reforçar as vocações
históricas de niterói niterói tem um
forte tem uma forte relação é da cidade
com o mar
vamos projetamos não estamos projetando
uma estação intermodal
a partir dessa centralidade que a
estação das barcas é comporta
estamos projetando a integração do
caminho maia ao centro da cidade
vamos construir também uma vila dos
pescadores o projeto prevê a construção
de uma vila de pescadores que certamente
se transforma se transformará no pólo
gastronômico e o projeto prevê também a
construção de uma grande esplanada em
frente nessa frente marítima hoje
obstruída uma frente esplanada de frente
para a baía de guanabara os niteroienses
as pessoas do estado e do brasil vão ter
orgulho de ver o centro de niterói
renovado transformar as cidades
significa transformar as pessoas
muito obrigada